hey Vsauce Michael here coming to you
from my hotel room in London with a
little camera that I taped to a bunch of
furniture I stacked up which is better
than nothing and as you can tell from
the title of this video it's also what
we're going to discuss nothing can there
ever be nothing
I mean we're surrounded by matter all
the time even this glass is not empty I
know you might think there's nothing in
it but it's full of air and air is
packed one cubic centimeter of air
contains almost 30 quintillion molecules
but if I remove the air from this glass
I can create what is known as a vacuum
an awesome word that uses a double U but
not a W the challenge however is
removing all of the air to this day the
best scientists have been able to do is
to create what they call an ultra-high
vacuum at this point one cubic
centimeter of space contains not 30
quintillion molecules but a mere and
amazing 102 put that in perspective a
vacuum cleaner like you use at home
hardly changes the fitness of the air at
all in fact if you use a vacuum cleaner
at sea level the vacuum created inside
the operational part of the machine only
has the thinness of air found in Denver
Colorado if you want thinner air if you
want even fewer particles per cubic
centimeter you're gonna have to leave
earth but before we go too far let's
talk about high altitude flying when
you're in an airplane 30,000 feet high
the outside air is very thin and
dangerous so by law the airplane must
keep the inside of that commercial
aircraft pressurized so that it only
feels like you're no more than 8,000
feet high
the reason it's dangerous is that when
air gets that thin there's not enough
oxygen for your brain this man is about
to remove his mask temporarily and with
supervision in the actual thinness of
the air around him within less than a
minute he suffers from hypoxia a lack of
oxygen
and even though he appears to be awake
and alert when told to put his mask back
on or else he will die he does nothing
but a lack of oxygen a lack of air a
lack of matter can get even more
dangerous when you go above 60,000 feet
about 19,000 meters above the surface of
the earth this limit is known as
Armstrong's limit we all know that the
boiling point of water decreases as your
altitude increases and at Armstrong's
limit the boiling point for your own
blood drops all the way down to the
temperature of your own body if you
reach that altitude without wearing a
special suit bubbles will form inside
your blood and your body will inflate to
twice it's normal size but because your
internal organs and your skin are
flexible you won't explode so let's talk
about outgassing outgassing
is why it's so difficult for us to reach
an ultra-high vacuum if you remove so
much air from this glass that there's
fewer than a hundred particles per cubic
centimeter the glass itself or whatever
material your chamber is made out of
will start to lose its own trapped gases
but materials don't need to be inside
partial vacuums to out gas it happens
all the time and is especially
noticeable in confined spaces for
instance a car all of the adhesives and
chemicals used to make that car will out
gas and collect inside creating what we
know as the new car smell all right time
to leave Earth for good let's go into
the space between planets now remember
that in a laboratory the best vacuum
we've been able to create is about a
hundred particles per cubic centimeter
well between the planets and our solar
system there is space that only contains
ten
particles per cubic centimeter and if
you leave our solar system into
interstellar space you're only gonna
find about one particle per cubic
centimeter the real winner though is
intergalactic space leave the Milky Way
all together and you can find regions
where there's only one or two particles
per cubic meter okay that's cool and all
but would it be possible to find a
region of space where there is
absolutely and literally nothing no
matter at all well according to quantum
mechanics no first of all you've got
gravitational and electromagnetic fields
that extend forever because the
particles that cause those fields to
happen have no mass whatsoever and this
is what's really mind-blowing there's a
thing known as virtual particles that's
happening all the time even around us
right now where there's no vacuum these
virtual particles come into existence
and then disappear and we believe they
exist for a couple of reasons one big
reason is the fact that our universe
continues to expand even though that
shouldn't necessarily happen where are
we getting that extra force that pushes
it that causes to keep expanding while
these particles that pop into existence
and disappear maybe the answer even
crazier is an effect we've observed
known as the Casimir force if you put
two pieces of metal nanometers apart
inside a vacuum they will be pushed
together one of the most popular
theories for why this happens is that
these virtual particles popping into
space and then disappearing are actually
reflecting off of the metal but because
the plates are so close together
particles with wavelengths longer than
that gap don't get reflected so there's
more virtual particles pushing on the
outside than the inside and the metal
plates contact
I know these concepts have gotten pretty
crazy but rest assured that really all
it means is that whenever you feel down
and feel like nothing matters you're
scientifically incorrect nothing matters
there can't be nothing
there's always matter there's always
something and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]